what turns you on do you like them real
or fake now come on then settle down i'm
not talking about boobs here i'm talking
trees have you opted for real or fake
this year
if you're like me you'll be sitting in a
beautifully
room staring at your magnificent nordman
fur
trying to convince yourself and your
green friends that christmas isn't
christmas
without a real tree anyway you already
do your bit for the environment so
taking a festive holiday from the eco
war doesn't make you a bad person
conversely
you could be in greta's camp and
currently find yourself sat around a
nasty
big fake tree and trying not to mind
because hey
you're saving the planet only guess what
you're not because according to the
carbon trust fake trees
have a carbon footprint 10 times greater
than a properly disposed of
real tree and for a fake tree to ever
make eco sense
you'd have to use it for 10 christmases
before it had a lower footprint than a
real one so stick that in your pipe
greta
[Music]
i think there are pros and cons i think
there are pros and cons to real trees
and i think there are pros and cons to
fake trees look here we are sitting
among
amid this festive splendor and sparkly
baubles of
one two three four fake i regret to tell
you
um trees but they look nice and you can
they'll probably be good for another 10
years
i don't i always have a real tree
because i like i like the delicious
piney scented
um aroma and i like having to hoover up
underneath the tree every day
and i can't imagine not having one and
it costs 14 million
pounds every year for people to recycle
take these trees to landfill and then of
course they contribute to global warming
but we have a win-win solution which is
offered by friends of the earth which is
that we all rent
our christmas trees and
we can then return it so we don't then
each have one which we then dispose of
can we let's go back to what we just
said about landfill
the responsible thing to do of course is
not to take a real tree to landfill what
you have to do
is you have to mulch it chop it or burn
it and most times when you buy a real
tree now because then it's
you know you see go sensible and most
times burn it carol it's not you know it
is it absolutely is it's
carbon trust says it's absolutely the
right thing to do but you know i bought
our
real treat last week and the guy i was
buying it off said do you want to
collect it
after christmas and i said what you're
going to do with it he said we're going
to mulch it and we use it for pavements
in our gardens
so that makes how often does that happen
now all the time seriously
yeah you said that in order for a
uh plastic tree to make eco sense it
would need to be used at least 10 times
or the plastic tree that i that my
family used when we were
i was four yeah we still kept using
until i was about 20. yeah but what did
it look like for me it was amazing look
terrible it was amazing it's not that
dust
christmas christmas tree
presumably um the johnson family
gathered around a twig did you when you
can't because i just got a tweet
because you talked about your tree so
let's take a look let's show the viewers
this
is rachel's christmas tree in all its
glory
very nice too nice let's have a look at
carol's christmas tree in all its glory
oh we're liking that and if i'm showing
yours i'd better show you mine here's
mine
yes it's outside that's outside my
london
[Laughter]
no i'm going to the states for christmas
so i am i
i always have a real tree i have a one
as big as that yeah you'll be in that
um which i love but this year i'm not
going to be there so i decided i don't
have you you don't need them so have you
got no bits and bobs
around the house nothing no that's not a
single decoration that's not on
you haven't got a tree uh well i'll be
going to my parents place so i'll be
using theirs just just the
the carbon footprint that if you have a
real tree
and you properly dispose of it it
creates 3.5 kilograms
that's that's the carbon footprint if
you have a fake tree it's 40
kilograms great do they carbon trees
they're made of pvc i mean plastic trees
they're made of pvc
there's a guy well that's the thing you
can't do anything and the processes
that make them no i'm on your side
there's a guy called stephen evans who's
the managing director of christmas tree
world
if such a person exists who said our
artificial trees can be found in
airports universities stately homes and
hospitals
they're flame retardant which is a major
thing for big public buildings
and hospitals use them because some
patients have allergies
you can use them year after year so the
money saving
is enormous where did you store a
plastic tree thought
in a shed